hello malice good you're looking rather
alright today just this page oh yeah it
goes well with your a place like really
makes it blue do you mind being on ok
I mean want to reintroduce yourself for
the sake of the I'm Ryan Maxwell right
I'm here observing today for my TV
production class oh cool cool nice I was
in TV production and in high school but
I went more for film when I got into
college but uh that's cool I love how
they leave the room as soon as I whip
out the camera it's like no Malcolm's
edit again run right oh man yeah I
remember like Oh zombie malice no oh
because it's the skins turn the peel on
oh yeah but like if your skin stays red
after it turns off so my face is just
gonna be like are you okay damn if you
have a fever or the train home yeah it's
perfect yeah now you won't be bothered
like you might have something infectious
shit I get my own but you know back in
demo reel um actually had like all that
same makeup Lee just splattered across
my face but it was because the Swedes
had slapped me with like some kind of
pancake okay sauce so yeah but I know
that feeling it's just like dry yeah I
can't write welcome back welcome back um
I say go ahead get in the UM gig in the
red sure we can probably find some
glasses for you okay ah as well and yeah
this is costume
uh he's just sort of like you know sort
of this like the business guy who's just
like you know looking through paperwork
actually have revenues oh no for the
bunny yeah no that's way that's gonna be
bill Jews with the rabbit is this okay
and that's him as this character but
then afterwards it cuts back I'd say
wait a minute
you know Rebecca yeah I gotta look
familiar and suddenly he's in the bunny
Abbey's like you know no I don't okay oh
and that's all if you get done shooting
the shot try to keep the camera there is
let's keep the camera in place
yeah okay just keep it in place for the
whole shop um so yeah go ahead get in
the kindle Richard alright um and yeah
well we'll see you in get the diaper
into okay and as you can see I am
becoming Malcolm juice or black rabbit
juice juice rabbit it's just gonna be
the rabbit right yeah got me
he says give you black eyes and whiskers
okay close your eyes
I was always so so bad with eye makeup
get all the way up to the eyebrow
creamy sweets want to try not touch it
because it'll just spread like mad if it
hasn't fact let me fix one area here now
I have spared no expense of artificial
whiskers
bring this is I'm gonna go talk to Tamra
and were you doing malice what are you
doing you can't be on the phone the damn
phones a victorian-era would you kill
malice I'm about to kill Malcolm awesome
yeah that's right you do kill him at the
end I'm excited about that um I feel
Johnny Depp and Helena Bonham Carter
exactly I can't say your name sir this
assistant like and that one her oh wait
dressing her Nettie is it like John
Travolta will come out backwards bomb
Carter Bonham Carter bonden but yes
sister you are like the John Travolta
machine sis's name generator' missus
that's one other thing people might find
interesting your natural laugh sounds
like an evil villain laugh yeah that's
her natural lap there's actually a scene
in Wicker Man we just laugh naturally
and I'm just like wait no that's like a
good evil laugh I'm gonna put that in
there my dad always used to say if he
heard that laugh he knew I was doing
something mean to my little brother it's
so true or like if my cat's do something
stupid and my my boyfriend hears it from
the other room he's like what are the
cats do like Mississippi just a MW
before I move who are you
I just some guy wandering off the street
I don't know what the hell's going on
around here
cool is this a sis assistant this is got
a night with a paper staying on it
oh oh that's great that look all right
that looks wonderful
you escaped from Zoo Belize ooh yeah do
you want me to do the bend on the ears
or I eat it you can put it right back
right yeah go ahead try one I think I'm
probably gonna like it just up oh my god
you know you look like you know you can
look like one the hyenas from Lion King
OS make mad a good Sam III keep on
straight up I think three one bit
really comes together with the wig yeah
the other way there yes it wasn't even
look this is just you look beautiful
it's assisted here can you make that I
always get this crazy air to Sister
Sister Sister well that's good you don't
have any year oh that is very long look
just like this just like that I'm sure
sexy like carrot juice yes let's just
let's get you two together that has to
be a picture wait no I recorded haha
don't ask me I'm sorry it's this one
okay
my bed my bed okay guys ready oh and
here we go I like the flavors grab
whatever listen I'm supposed to learn
and you're gonna come you're gonna
actually hold the position you know why
they're gonna get up go over here do
your pose well hey and then I'm gonna
get up come over here go get it
oh hey and then yeah then you can do are
you gonna are you gonna cut between so
we get pierced up yeah crazy boy yeah
thank you sir
all right so I'll put all the in phasis
on my right honestly I don't
I don't even to say what hey I think we
can build that later I thought be
funnier and more clear so just focus on
getting like a we love that look Adam
okay you know shoot for you oh thanks
are we moving though corny yep yes
really
so I completely forgot whatever message
I was supposed to learn and then wait
like five seconds and yet just go ahead
get yourself establish and Tamra you and
me we're just gonna try and hold our
spots as long as possible
you're the knife right yes okay um and
obviously when you come in and try your
business too much don't hurt him too
much
I have my charities okay okay
and Tamra yeah you're watching the TV
too we both just look unimpressed pretty
much raised hammer yeah
ready Malcolm I completely forgot
whatever lesson I was supposed to learn
oh good no my ears are we looking at the
camera a reaction looking cute
well we're look at the game oh okay
again this one oh how can we do that it
was perfect Oh destroy okay and action
I completely forgot whatever less and I
was supposed to learn
you look like one of the evil cats from
because evil cat scan and you can stew
evil cat screws let me double check I
think we're done with you as malice but
let me just check and make sure who's
that clocks my right by the way right
it's three minutes to five oh it's gonna
be five in just a couple okay oh then my
calorie behinds good Wow okay yeah so so
that's it for you is that you can get
changed
alright what'd you get in there uh I'm
the helm about Carter Helena Bonham
Carter this is it yeah we've referenced
them so much Lord Allah
yeah Oh Timbo it's coming off your that
a really black head so is that your real
hair color the brown the brown is yeah
hmm we have a say if you can't go back
yep oh yeah before I do so uh any bigger
you like pizza I like it all
she likes it all she likes are you
Malcolm uh I'm cool with spinach or
manic yeah okay dad okay yeah how about
Jesus pages that son good yeah yes okay
yes everyone represent yeah yeah
so now oh yeah yeah that's been like
forever
yeah I'm 67 years old forever man that's
true
I I don't know I ever since I was born
has been around I was out in California
when of this one place and they had this
pizza and brought it to me ahead
Canadian bacon and pineapple and I said
wow I mean this was way way way back in
the in the early 70s oh you know and I
said wow what is it
this guy says I don't know we're
thinking of call it pineapple pizza or
tropical pizza or Hawaiian pizza wow
this is the first place that ever did it
it's crazy to call the a-440 pizza house
that's my favorite pizza is well
pineapple on anything it's my favorite
oh yeah I love pineapple
I never eat I've never tried it on pizza
the bacon part I don't think I'll ever
get to try cuz well vegetarian yeah okay
usually all is your up the blood that
was awesome we got I got a big hose out
here if you want to just stand off hose
you that's gonna be amazing - is it does
that come off easy you're dead
yeah uh what did you do with the mouse
on the and this is the late-night
edition of nostalgia critic yeah oh and
it's a good welcome Steve yeah pizza
with critic always in critic you did
critic this done yeah sure you recognize
this is it yes after enough I'm the
critic all right I uh I think obviously
has left in a while right I'm a new
critics newbie Snoopy okay good
and it turns out that we're actually uh
related somehow yeah I didn't know it we
were separated at birth and now we're
gonna
still review show together totally yeah
anomalous and carrot juice whole
stingers show would have to be kind of
Awesome yeah that's true that would be
an interesting sake carrot juice and
Alice so what makes sense yeah I'm gonna
do it but you're close man
you know the bottle Carter oh yes I have
to take I will she's in my well I'll
have to edit that out
no I'm probably gonna leave that in
that's funny I buy my own machete it's
your first time ever being like yeah I
can use you just but yeah I don't know
it'll be interesting white makeup what's
good or not cuz I because my possibly
look more alike and without it but maybe
I really want them to match and
especially if they're in Burton land
right it would make sense that they
would like you know be on there yeah
have the white makeup on she's British
of course you would be cool see the Sun
was
have you seen the Harry Potter movies
remember no you haven't
oh she's she pretty much uses the same
corpse bride it's not the same it's the
same thing you doing before the same
boys are doing with mouths try to make
it blow it okay
he's Tweedledum and tweedle clever yeah
they sense yeah I think she has a deeper
voice
Doug's transformation the Casper is
there right be here to chaos and over
here we have uh Optimus Cthulhu we never
put together
Optimus come do it right you're sitting
right from honey yeah in the captain's
chair at that I was looking I'm like
yeah who's that a thing or you just it's
just the way the props fell doing this
gets us around here ten figures okay Oh
receptor oh that's like talking to eat
lean the simplicity not hearing what's
up it's cool talking through your teeth
not hearing what's it okay uh you know
what
and then well enter that we're going to
improvise because it does really matter
what we say because we're going to cut
to you and me as the critic and malice
so like just try to make up a rhyme and
I'll just be like no no that doesn't
right now you need to do it this way and
we'll just talk back it but it doesn't
really matter
oh yeah
all right right I am action who would
want fun when this glue instead that's
like talking through your teeth not
hearing what said I'm wearing stripes in
a jacket of whoo doing so would be
incredibly cool oh that's a nice right
it doesn't work okay I studied Supes I
had you with your what I'm cool you're
cool okay that's good and I hope that it
feels always really it seems it doesn't
we shouldn't wear this the things makeup
okay you - I'm not sure you know just my
body's completely red all of this I get
a haircut I need to get a tattoo above
three on my hand
definitely no bracelets no just a tattoo
over three I really have oh I know you
kid yeah because by this point it
doesn't really matter because it's
probably done recording no I really
haven't and two or three because I'm
sure I def on that fucking insane wait
okay that was amazing
Jack you get to over 300 it's just like
103 there he really has a three there
this is Wow who would want fun when this
glue instead glue instead I'm here for
awesome probably a good time for glue
your teeth shut yes I am actually
who would want fun with this glue
instead I forgot my life you have glue
in your teeth
all right ready yes and action
who would what fun when this glue
instead that's like talking through your
teeth not hearing what said my hair is
curly your hair straight straight why
straight why can't it be my right no
that was terrible I really don't know
that was great wasn't her ski died dude
there's like three rides no no what you
did was break my mind was not so pretty
I righteous it was mediocre
great why better use the word write this
up that's much better I'm it's okay
everyone is confused by that so they've
melted under the run it's like I'm
hypnotized enough see that's good I like
that
I like this do you gonna like this I'll
go like this okay can I do yes no no
like this
oh because you're who okay I am the
Google a dancer yes you are together we
will rule other but to lose it it was
just so ridiculous wow the world great
doug is a Waldo mine well no here's a
wall don't mind where's pretty much oh
yeah you know here's my mom there is a
bottom circle them psyche you have to
pretend to have glasses yes
hahahaha I'm a very mean but yeah three
and the train comes at eight oh four and
nine oh four oh okay well we might be
able to maybe sir Wonderland is checking
up on the prophecy told her to check
their calendar thing every day
and Narnia doom chosen matrix Phantom
Menace Jesus good
oh the only one that got a little gentle
was Narnia see you so you can tone down
the accident touching that one okay but
all the others were good yeah another
which was look good sir Wonderland is
checking up on their prophecy and Narnia
doom matrix Phantom Menace Jesus good
try one like this uh dune matrix phantom
as like this one this one this one so
now as much frustrated like you just
don't give a crap okay good yeah I go
ahead just are fun beginning to with
that sir
Wonderland is checking up on their
prophecy and Narnia dune matrix Phantom
Menace Jesus perfect
cool really yeah yeah um well you double
check I think that's it mmm-hmm
and that's a wrap in the wonderful world
of anna lhasa I can't be it says here
we're wrapping up at 10 o'clock
really and I love fishing and this'll
really happens it's been happen we've
been fishing on time usually yeah that's
pretty good
it's like your joy was and besides by
like the dark rings I'm so happy if you
want one Halloween I think lasting out
the Joker makeup because I did a
Halloween uh uh
Joker catching one Halloween I dip it in
for two oh but when I was washing the
makeup off uh the black was smearing all
over the place I mean even more than
like you know what was in the Dark
Knight movie and it got like above the
eyebrow it was all over and it's it's
the scariest thing if you can just take
like a ton of black and just like the
size of your hand just like this over
each one it just have like the darkest
be in the center cuz then when you get
your eyes really big like this it's so
creepy just to have something so white
in the middle of like all the smeared
darkness is like oh wow it's great
Halloween Kasia ha ha
that's why skeletons are so creepy
because it got all the black around
there yeah and they're even creepier if
you've ever seen as guilty and suddenly
has a human eyes in the middle oh yeah
well there's a good Talon tip for
everybody yes
yeah it gets darker when I aim it
towards the ceiling
Oh sister this well that's a wrap
awesome
ah alright and iron okay
always prepared
that's good